foreign
hey everybody it's Monday we're talking
about a haunting yeah Hugo said is this
the one with the killing doll no no it's
not no um Child's Play he's telling the
kill he's talking about yeah it is no no
yeah this is nothing nothing to do with
Chucky this is actually uh an episode of
a haunting I'm not entirely sure why
this one is called Child's Play they're
running out of names I guess yeah but
it's like I don't know why because this
is a fairly I mean it's not recent
recent but for a haunting it's recent
because I think this came out of what
2014 or 2015 or something like 2016.
yeah it's it's a season seven yeah 2014
I think yeah I mean the story takes
place in 2013 and 2014. so I'm assuming
it's just a year or two after that so
you know so there's really no excuse
they knew about the movie so I don't
know why they would call it that and
like I said it doesn't really have that
much do yes there is a child involved
but yeah the demon really kind of like
[__] with everybody so yeah is that
actually kind of like a part two to the
of the one we did last week because this
involves this the guy who does the
investigation in this and who's telling
this story is the guy who was one of the
ghost victims of the last ghost victim
yeah that's yeah well that's kind of
there's two reasons why I wanted to do
this one even though I'm gonna say a
brunt it's not a great episode no it's a
little bit repetitive not a lot happens
but I am gonna say okay so last week we
did nightmare in the Attic right which
was also season seven and on that one
that was like the fox family so we had
Wesley Fox who was a kid when that [__]
happened and then they said then I found
out while I was researching that episode
that that guy grew up and became a
Paranormal Investigator and that he was
one of the people that investigated this
case which they also covered on this now
he also wrote a book about this case
which is the cupid family not Cupid but
Cupid with a t yeah and um it was
available on Kindle unlimited for free
so actually
um I read I did didn't quite finish it
because it was like I was thinking that
it was going to be one of those
paranormal books like about a case where
it's like 50 pages long and like really
badly written however this one was
actual book length it was 222 pages and
it was actually like pretty well written
for this kind of thing like I was like
wow it's actual grammatically correct
and everything like you could tell that
there was like a lot of filler in it
like I'm not gonna say that but it was
padded out a little bit well a little
bit just in the sense that and Jen's an
author so she knows well I was just in
the sense that there was like some
scenes where it's like people were
calling up and being like you know hello
hey how are you doing you know what I
mean like like conversations and [__]
that didn't really need to be in there
but it's like it wasn't really that bad
so I actually read most of it like I
didn't like read it read it but I
skimmed through it because I was like
looking for and the thing about it is
that according to this book like way
more cool [__] happened in the case like
I don't know if it really happened or
not but it's just like according to the
story according to the store story like
way more cool [__] happened that they
didn't put in the episode and it's like
it really would have
um made the episode a lot more exciting
if they had put some of the [__] that
was in the book in there but for some
reason they did not so you could say
that okay did the book predate The
episode
I don't think so because the cover of it
says as featured on a haunting or
something like that unless they did a
new cover later on right I'm not really
sure but I mean I think the book came
out around the same time as the episode
okay so all right
hopefully it wasn't a situation where
the episode came out
they weren't too impressed with the
episode they said we can beat that and
write the book make it we're gonna make
a little more exciting this time
but I'm gonna say that that's what
happened but yeah I don't know it's like
from the timing of it it seemed like
they came out at around the same time
so
I guess you know so when you could say
based on what you're telling me this
episode might be a teaser for the book
yeah because like I said the book the
book is a lot more like there's a lot
more like Poltergeist type activity and
[__] like that which I don't think they
shared any of that no not in the episode
the episode like I said seemed like a
lot of feelings yeah I was being watched
feelings and a lot of like filler yeah
but I think that that kind of happened a
lot with the later episodes because one
thing that I noticed that they started
doing in about like season six or seven
was that you know uh you know they would
do like a segment and then it would go
to Commercial and then it would came
back from commercial they would like
essentially repeat most of the [__] they
just said so when you're watching it
without commercials you're just kind of
like okay well you can skip over the
first 30 seconds or a minute or
something after it comes back in the
commercial because they're just
reiterating everything that just
happened now when you talk about a case
that hinges on feelings
I'm not going to say that that's fake
because uh for those of you who are new
to the show
Me growing up as a kid my family had a
whole Poltergeist thing happened and
Jenny wrote a book about it later on
when we told her the story called mavic
Mountain Poltergeist had pictures of it
took pictures of [__] that had been
moved and stacked up and turned upside
down you know a little Polaroid camera
at the time and everything so it was
something that happened and we tried to
prove get evidence as much as we could
back in the 80s early 80s you know but
it's just a story now and I've seen that
I know that's real
later on many many years later after
getting out of the army and having some
other [__] happen like a near-death
experience and everything
moved into a house that was a bad house
me and my Army buddy moved into it
together and every girl we brought over
and everybody we had [__] visit us
they were scared of that house you'd
have to walk them to the bathroom and
they'd use the bathroom and then you'd
walk them back to the halls and no one
could put their finger on it it was just
feelings and bad dreams and stuff
that was real but I could never prove it
it was just based on feelings nothing
ever moved
too subjective
you know yeah so I can understand a case
that is basically just feelings
because some of them are just like that
they're not strong enough to move
anything but they're not that cinematic
I mean you can't make a movie about them
right because it's just kind of like you
just can't make a movie with people just
going
and it's like for two hours and it's
hard to and it's hard to make a a uh a
convincing
case in a paranormal investigation for
anything because it's just feelings
there's nothing to measure another
record no physical evidence
so I can understand the conundrum you
know yeah you know there's something
wrong with this place but you just can't
prove it
it's just feelings when you get in there
so I'm not going to knock it if that's
if the way the case really was as if it
was shown as as it was in the episode
doesn't mean it wasn't real
I wasn't there I didn't experience it
maybe it was way crazier in the book
yeah it's crazy but like yeah they
should have put that in the episode
that's what I'm saying because I'm
sitting there reading the book like I
said I don't necessarily believe any of
it really happened but I was like why
did they put all this [__] in the in the
episode that would have made it like a
lot more exciting you know what I'm
saying
Tom Sykes says a family of Bible
smackers in this one yeah yeah it
happens I mean they seemed like nice
people I'm not I'm not it doesn't just
doesn't discredit the the case
um usually
yeah the people involved in any kind of
paranormal case have some kind of a
spiritual belief system even if it's
some kind of a moral belief system and
they're gonna put that into this case
they're going to see it through that
lens so just because it's Christians
seeing it doesn't mean it wasn't
happening just because it was Muslims
seeing it it doesn't mean it didn't
happen just because atheists saw it
doesn't mean that it didn't happen
you're going to color it with whatever
lens that you use as your basis basic
perspective you know what I mean so
everybody's gonna tell the story
according to their basic belief systems
you know must be a demon you know must
be a ghost must be a gin there must be
psychic forces you know they're going to
have us come up with an explanation that
they can live with
which is the way it is
I think what we might do on this show
we'll just kind of go over the because
you just re-watched this right yeah I
saw it twice yes okay because we watched
it last night and then I watched it
again earlier and took notes while I was
watching it and then he watched it again
probably like an hour ago yeah and it's
still kinda
flimsy in the episode
yeah but like I said we'll talk about
the episode and then at the end I'll go
into like all the [__] that I found in
the book that was a lot more interesting
that they probably should have put into
the episode like I said it didn't quite
finish the book I was just I was like
hurrying to like finish the the [__] so
I was just kind of like skimming and I
was like well it just kind of looks like
more of the same and it kind of looked
like it was good and it ends the same
way exorcism comes and you know oh this
and everything right and everything
and everything's fine yeah the smell of
sex the smell of sanctity man that's
another like audio clip that I should
have yeah we should write that down of
like Lorraine Warren go the smell of
sanctity
it wouldn't surprise was it actually
even her or was it the actress playing
her I think it was I think it was the
action the actress playing yeah because
I think it was like a reenactment yeah
and she was goofing on it too I think a
little bit the smells
I mean it's really really hard to say
that with a straight face yeah it
wouldn't surprise me if [__] little
brain had a little hidden bottle of
spray bottle of [__] Rose [__]
cold that's what I'd be doing
roses the smell you guys smell that
[__] you got that at seven lips
put that car air freshener back she's
waving back in those days I used to sell
air fresheners in a metal a little metal
can they were they were uh and it was
like a banaka remember the banana yeah
yeah
I remember those we used to buy them
yeah if I could spray them in the car
after you're smoking weed in the car it
didn't hide the seeds no of course it
just Blended in there with some we need
roses
it's like strawberry weed strawberry but
she probably would get a 7-Eleven on her
way there to get the Roses yeah when
you're not looking
and then she Stir It Around hey you
smell that
smell is sanctity I mean that seems like
a really easy thing to do yeah they did
that kind of [__] man of course why
wouldn't you like I said that's totally
what I would do yeah if I you know if I
didn't have a conscience and I wanted to
like five people well a lot of people in
that business you know it was parlor
tricks going back to like seances and
stuff yeah of course
Tom Sykes said I'm actually glad you
brought this up because this was exactly
what I was thinking he said this episode
seemed made up kinda like the little
girl was reading [__] written for her to
say and not her own words I thought that
too and I think like I even actually
wrote that down on my notes I said some
of the stuff she says doesn't sound like
something a 10 year old kid yes an adult
would say so I kind of feel and the way
she was saying it and the little girl in
this like she's huge as hell she's not a
little girl anymore obviously she's like
she's 20 snaps she's 20 now I guess
because she was 10 when this episode was
2014. but yeah she's adorable yeah um
but some of the stuff she said it really
did sound like someone was I wrote down
it sounded like someone was coaching her
yeah like somebody had written down like
yeah like she was reading off a
teleprint well we don't know we weren't
there you know yeah I don't know I'm
just saying that yeah it seemed like
have you ever done any kind of [__]
corporate-based production me and Jenny
[__] went to studio and did [__] for
[__] NPR and stuff
it's you to to execute the the job you
already know pretty much what you're
gonna say they tell you okay here this
is when you're going to tell us about
when this happened over here this is
when you're going to tell us that we're
going to spool it in they're making
something so it's it's going to sound
canned especially you know it just does
a person who's not really used to to
that it sounds kind of canned so I think
it might have been a little bit of like
stage fright in a certain way and that
would stage I think she just might have
been a little bit uncomfortable in front
of cameras
maybe but I'm gonna say when I get
toward the end because there was one
particular thing that she said that I
was like that really doesn't sound like
something a 10 year old kid they're
Southern they're from Arkansas yeah yeah
they're Southern Arkansas family and uh
her name was Brittany and spelled with
eyes all eyes
b-r-i-t-t-n-i yeah yeah I mean I saw
that [__] start laughing you know like a
she's a stripper now I wear the name
like I was like yeah
in the south is it that's a stripper
damn
I yeah it's I I was just like because I
was I think in my notes I even wrote God
that spelling like that yeah she was
cute though yeah she's cute as [__] a
little kid on here it was like adorable
but like I'm not blaming her it's not
her fault but like I said I hope she's
not a stripper well unless she wanted to
be a stripper you know what I mean but
like I said that's it is different
tobacco bar that is definitely a
stripper yeah like spelled like that
yeah
but yeah
sorry kid I know you're not a kid
anymore but yeah we just thought that
was funny we're just Clowning uh so yeah
all right so let's talk about this
episode so this takes place the the
events took place in 2013 so you know
fairly recent this is only a decade ago
in a very small town called Greenbrier
Arkansas which is just outside of Little
Rock I've never been to Arkansas in my
entire life so I really don't know that
much about Greenbrier at all
so we're following a married couple
whose names are Chris and Roseanne cupit
and their two kids who at the time I
guess were Justin was their son and he
was 13 and Brittany with an I was 10
years old uh so yeah Roseanne said this
is kind of like a small town everybody
knows everybody kind of thing it's like
you know because they call it a bedroom
community
you know
now uh much is made in the episode of
these unusual the Red Rooster comb
flowers which are pretty weird looking
and they're actually like really pretty
I like them but Chris's grandmother used
to grow them and I think in the episode
they kind of made it seem like the
family had just moved to this house or
is that me I mean you watched it like
just an hour ago so did it seem to you
like they said oh we just moved there
because that's not how it happened like
in the book they had actually been there
a long time yeah I think it kind of did
lead you to believe they had just moved
there see that's what I thought like I
don't think they came right out and said
that but because they shot it kind of
from I don't really remember yeah this
particular episode A lot of it the the
way it's formatted is kind of generic at
this point we're talking about
we're talking about season seven yeah
season seven became very
samey
you know
yeah not just season seven
but you know it started to get saved me
around five six
I mean there's only so much you can do
in that framework you know what I mean
because if you go too crazy it all
starts you get I've been possessed by a
mummy and like now there's green scaly
people they're haunting me that's what I
mean and it's like but you know I kind
of feel like you're you you're either
gonna do that and just go completely
batch it insane or they're all gonna be
kind of like the same because they're
formatted in a way you can only tell
stories like this only so many ways so
it's it's going into format
and the stories are all kind of similar
a lot so you
and and the titles are kind of similar
we have a hard time remember what the
titles there are and [__] what is
called what you know what episode is
called what it's easy to you know be on
the door
death Among Us Darkness has passed
yeah into the darkness
Darkness up here Darkness over there
yeah Darkness behind you Darkness behind
Darkness above Darkness unbelief
like I said I think they have like that
little I think they just have all the
words and they throw them in half a man
ghost in the tree what yeah because
there were seven when the where the
ghost sound like they could have called
one called that [__] ghost in the tree
ghost in the tree yeah I mean you know
tree Darkness within I think they
actually did have one more Darkness
within didn't they Darkness inside
Darkness within something like that
Darkness inside her
that's the porn version yeah
but yeah it's interracial Yeah well yeah
sure yeah of course
anyway these are so fun we always end up
talking about porn or food I don't know
why that is
no I know why that is
I know where that is I'm pretending
we've got to be serious here man we're
doing a serious investigation of this
[__] case Okay
um yeah
yeah but yeah so what I was saying why I
got off on that tangent yeah was because
of like the red flowers they kind of
made it seem like it's like oh we saw
these flowers growing up front and it
was almost like a sign like um that was
the house we were supposed to have
because Chris's grandmother used to grow
them and so he always Associated uh
those flowers with his grandmother but
like I said they kind of made it seem
like they just moved to this house but
that's not the case because I read the
book so I'll get into that like a little
bit later now uh Chris says that he
still feels his grandmother's presence
like watching over him she died in 2003.
now on the show like in the reenactment
it actually showed him seeing her
although he never said that on the show
um I'll get into like that because they
did go more into that in the book but
like I said
um on the show he didn't say that he
ever seen her he just says that it
seemed like he just referred to like a
warm happy presence around them like and
she and he could feel that she was there
you know what I mean and then Brittany
the little girl she said she always said
that her dad always said oh Grandma's
here like watching over you and she's
like oh that's nice you know it's
keeping us from getting hurt or whatever
so uh yeah so this family is uh yeah
real religious now Chris apparently went
to church a lot when his grandmother was
alive but had stopped going I don't
think he stopped going completely or
anything but like he didn't go as much
like after she died
but recently the family has started to
get like a lot more back into that
um I guess because like the kids were
getting a little bit older and they just
kind of wanted the kids they were trying
to like instill their values or whatever
and they thought like the kids were old
enough to understand now or appreciate
it or blah blah so they started doing
what they call daily devotionals and
spending a lot more time at church [__]
like that like they doing the whole
praying in a circle in the living room
thing like reading Bible stories every
night the whole deal uh like I said we
were both very amused because these are
from there from Arkansas so we were both
very amused by Roseanne's pronunciation
of the Bible yeah yeah yeah Bible Bible
doing the Bible the Bible stories yeah
365 Bible stories Bible stories yeah
yeah so they got one a day
and then they're like sitting around
reading them which I don't know it's
just it doesn't really sound like a good
time for me but Mississippi
[Laughter]
yeah
Tom Sykes says how did the house even
become infested with demonica activity
again oh we'll get into that yeah we'll
get into that
all right we're just [__] with them
if y'all
are watching us
make fun of your case or [__]
we're Southern twos we're just [__]
with you okay yeah I mean you know yeah
take the piss I'm I'm from Florida yeah
she's a stripper too so it's okay
named Brittany with an eye
Jenny with a high I actually used to
spell it like that when I was a kid well
just because I had I went to school with
so many other girls named Jenny that I
was like well maybe I should spell it a
different way
but I went back to the White House I and
instead of a DOT on top of how he had a
little star did you
now okay
[Laughter]
but you should have done should put a
little star
I know I wasn't that bad okay
uh but yeah so they're reading all these
all these Bible stories the Bible
stories so while they're apparently
while their uh faith is getting stronger
in that way like something starts
[__] with them like one family member
at a time and again this is why this
episode seemed like a little bit
repetitive because it's like hey we're
standing around praying and then
suddenly somebody's like
what is it I feel an evil presence that
it like happens to each one of them like
pretty much except for Chris
so it starts with Roseanne the mom like
while they're doing their prayer circle
deals she's saying the prayer and then
she senses evil I'm like yeah I've done
that before like since it's evil yeah
that's what I said every time somebody
says that every time somebody says that
in the episode I always look at him and
go yeah I've sent some evil in here
before yeah like had to spray you with
Febreze abdominal Snowman
Florida's concave right exactly yeah
that shouldn't happen anymore though it
doesn't happen yeah I changed my weight
yeah look man we gotta get back on the
[__] chair all right gotta get back
on the channel so uh yeah she actually
described it the real lady she actually
described it as an uneasy feeling and
unnerving that's what she said it it
felt like like she didn't see anything
she was just kind of like ooh I said
it's evil you know what I mean yeah
um now it's then revealed that she had
she had felt the same sense of dread as
a child when her and her friends were
playing with guess what one of those
evil
Ouija boards yeah at a sleepover another
Trope yeah I mean Parker Brothers
brought so many demons into this world
that's what I know I wrote that in my
notes too it's like blame the poor
Parker Brothers
and blame the woman they always do I
wonder if you could sue them
I know well Parker Brothers were
probably like yeah [__] it just like
they probably think it's like well it's
just it just sells more Ouija boards
yeah okay yeah we'll give you six
thousand yeah put that at the newspaper
that we yeah we're bringing in demons
we totally do our [__] works I mean yeah
well that's what I mean if I worked for
Parker Brothers I would just lean into
that [__] because that's gonna make
people want it more yeah
calling demons man I'm all into it
Zach says uh no it has to be spelled
j-y-n-e-e
yeah
that looks more like Johnny but okay
yeah that's like the porn version
Tom Sykes says supposedly the family
were on the level of religious like
Mommy and Daddy from the film The People
Under the Stairs yeah I mean I haven't
seen that yeah you did we reviewed it
like one of the stairs yeah it's Wes
Craven
a lot of times I see I don't remember it
yeah we did we reviewed it a couple
years back but uh yeah I don't know they
were quite that bad but yeah it was it
was on that Spectrum for sure okay I
think I kind of remember what it was all
John Spectrum for sure
uh so yeah so there's actually like a
flashback of that whole situation of her
like [__] with the evil Ouija board
and like she was the one that brought
this whole thing down on everybody
because you know always gotta blame
gotta blame the woman and blame the
Ouija boards
so later that night Roseanne is overcome
with a sensation again uh while she's
standing in the kitchen she said she
felt like extremely cold she said the
cold went from one side of her body all
the way around to the back now of course
at first she thought it might be the AC
but she goes up to the vent and it's
like it's not on
so then she said she felt the hair on
the back of her neck stand up and felt
like someone was in the room with her
she called it a spine tingly feeling
that was the quote she used
she looks out the window she locks the
door she doesn't see anybody
and then she goes in the living room and
turns out all the lights
um holding a candle like to make things
more atmospheric I guess
and then there's a pal like there's a
demon jump scare like she turns around
and it's like ah like this big [__]
it's just looking like a demon man with
the horns and the teeth and everything
and she screams her [__] hat off now
I guess she actually did see something
because she did note that it was just a
what she called a quick glimpse
that Disturbed her but she didn't really
describe what she saw exactly now when
when I get into the stuff that was in
the book like I'll talk a little bit
more about that but she didn't really
say oh my God I saw a [__] demon you
know what I mean so he comes down he's
like you know what the [__] are you
screaming at like he didn't say it like
that he was much nicer but um like what
are you screaming at and she's just like
oh nothing I just you know she just
didn't want to tell him
um also I will note that they had a
painting of Jesus on their wall in the
living room and next to Elvis and it
looked like uh hippie Edgar Allan Poe oh
yeah yeah like the face because I was
like wow that looks just like Edgar
Allan Poe that was in the episode yeah
in the episode yeah but it says I just
thought I would write that down because
it made me laugh that was like his face
looks just like a girl
I never saw one that looked like that
before when I was a kid it would have
been basically Jesus on velvet right
next to us Elvis on velvet and they
would look a lot alike
the only difference Jesus was just Elvis
with a beard
I mean you know yeah Anthony asked if we
had seen uh Megan yet no we haven't but
it's like I really do want to see it
like it looks really good which one was
that it's in the theaters right at the
moment it's kind of the one that's it's
all the buzz right now
do you remember that movie The
Changeling oh yeah that's one of my
favorite movies from the 70s actually
like one of my favorite Haunted House
movies of all time I think we reviewed
it a couple of years back well maybe
longer than that I think it was a while
back we did that one
um so yeah so the daughter Brittany has
also been having some paranormal
experiences uh but initially they're of
a much more benign nature so Chris the
dad walks by her room one day and hears
her like singing or humming this
particular song like while she's playing
with her dolls and he remembers it as a
song that his grandmother used to sing
to him when he was little
now he's sure that he's never told
Brittany about this song and Grandma
actually died before Britney was born
so grit so Chris like comes in and says
where'd you hear that and Brittany said
that she heard a voice telling her Susie
Q so she told her dad oh Susie Q and
then this freaked Chris out too because
he said his grandma would always refer
to somebody as Susie Q if she couldn't
remember their name
like so he was like weirded out by that
and he's like and I'm pretty sure like
we never said that to the kid
um now the show like the reenactment has
the ghost to Grandma like reaching out
to touch Brittany's hair which seems a
little creepy I mean the way they have
it uh but again the real kid never said
that she saw an apparition of the
grandma so you know so there's that and
I don't think I ever saw it I didn't see
it in the book either like I said I just
skimmed through but
so then they're doing another devotional
prayer circle thing like they do every
day and this time it's Brittany that
fear feels like the weird evil presence
in the room which kind of like makes her
stop talking and like look around like
what the [__] was that you know what I
mean
um she said it felt like something was
watching her
and
um she says I thought it was my
imagination so I just kept it to myself
like and like I said this little girl is
adorable
um and she was just like very very
serious and look I even wrote my notes
honestly some of the stuff she said
sounded as though she'd maybe been
coached
to deliver the lines in front of the
camera but it might have been
things that she said before in the past
maybe because you're like a robot up
there in front of that camera
that's true she just yeah I mean maybe
she was just wigged out but I don't know
but like I said some of the stuff she
said didn't really sound like something
a 10 year old kid would say although
that's kind of what it was like uh when
I went to Mammoth Mountain I could feel
that thing [__] watching me I just I
thought it was my imagination I blew it
off but so was everybody else yeah
everybody kind of says that on this show
because I guess that's like the natural
reaction because you're just like well
that was some weird [__] but maybe I
just like
move within minutes and then denied that
I saw that I was like nah that didn't
happen
well yes I think that's a very natural
salmon some no you know it must have
fell over you know I just but no I
didn't see it right yeah I didn't see it
right but yeah because
yeah you can't accept it right
so uh at this point the narrator says
something has been awakened in the house
he says it like that
so while Britney is sleeping she gets
woke up at three in the morning by I
guess like the feeling of something in a
room at least according to the
reenactment and maybe the sound of
breathing breathing or something like
that
so she sits up and sees the demon like
in the room like growling and reaching
for this claws though for some reason he
doesn't ever seem to get any closer to
her like so I was kind of laughing
because he was I guess because the actor
like couldn't move because he was green
screened or whatever and they just
superimposed him over the shot but so he
was just sitting there going ah
and she's like you know screaming it
right around but he's not like chasing
her or nothing like that so he's just
kind of like grasping at the air which I
thought was kind of funny so she runs to
the door of her room but for some reason
she can't get it open so she kind of
ends up cowering in the corner and like
praying for God to protect her and then
at this point the little girl the real
little girl says it was like hell
and that again that struck me as a very
strange thing for a 10 year old kid to
say but maybe not like a real religious
one I don't know just like the
inflection that she used was just very
strange but like I said I don't know
this kid so you know
so she runs in her parents room and
tells them about it but they thought it
was just a nightmare and I will say that
even after like I went through the book
and everything I'm not super clear on
what [__] the kid actually saw when she
was awake and what [__] was a nightmare
it's kind of ambiguous
and I'm kind of thinking that this
particular event was maybe a nightmare
because the way she talked about it
sounded like she was talking about a
nightmare but then like maybe she's like
oh but it was real so I don't know I
don't know if she just dreamed it or
what the [__] the deal was because when
I was reading the book there was some
stuff in there and I was like holy [__]
that's crazy but then they'd be like oh
it was a dream you know what I mean so I
don't know so like I said it's very very
ambiguous
so she sleeps with Mom and Dad that
night now the entity keeps coming back
she's like it just kept coming back like
more and more often like it'd be once a
week and then a couple times a week and
then it was every night
um Justin the older brother he starts
getting worried about her it's like she
doesn't tell him exactly what's going on
at first she just says oh I have really
bad nightmares I don't want to talk
about it
um and the real kid said you know I kept
praying to make the nightmares stop but
they wouldn't and Chris was like well
you know we knew something was the
matter with her because she was like all
sad all the time and like quiet and she
wasn't like she was but they didn't
really know how to help her because she
wouldn't say anything
so then the what sounded off a lot like
a bad house yeah maybe have been
something similar to what me and Eric
saw up in Boston
it was just a bad house just an
unnatural Stillness of feelings of being
watched feelings of having something
just looking at or at you at the side of
your head real close uh have real bad
dreams in there because you're under
like under it feels like some pressure
like oppression you know
you don't ever see anything move
do you know I mean maybe it was a
situation like that they embellished it
slightly
to make a better book or a better
episode because you're saying that yeah
I saw this demon and this dude it was
just a dream
yeah so you have to include the dreams
in the action
the dreams become the action for the the
action scenes for the for the episode
yeah
maybe what they're doing I kind of feel
like yeah may have been nothing more
than just what what I would call a bad
house
a place that is strong with the dark
side
because man I mean I could write all
kind of [__] about nightmares I've had
over the years but it's like you know
what I mean it's just yeah but when you
find a place like this it is paranormal
but it's not physical
you know what I mean it doesn't move
anything
it's not strong enough but it's strong
enough to [__] with you
you know me uh give you bad dreams I
don't know if the dreams are a direct an
artifact that is [__] psychically
blasted into your skull and it's
messages from the or if you're inventing
it because you're under so much stress I
don't know you know what I mean yeah I
can't having dreams about [__]
starving puppies in the pipes and in the
water pipes and [__] you know weird [__]
and
dreaming that I [__] rolled over and
looked down on the side of the bed it
could see through all the floors of the
house and it went down into [__] just
in abyss of [__] Dungeons and [__]
deep underneath there just weird and
[__] you know
I don't know if some kind of ghost is
making you see that or if you're just
having bad dreams because you're under
some kind of weird spiritual oppression
I don't know
you just you just gotta roll with it you
know
but nothing ever happened we eventually
just moved out of there yeah
so this demon uh then starts [__]
with Justin and his crazy emo hair
he was 13. yeah she looked like he was
blowing in the wind blowing he just
brushed his [__] in a circle
I just want to let that [__] grow
cut a little bit so it doesn't cover his
face I remember this looking Americans
that's why I kind of laughed this is
like 2014. yeah dated as [__] yeah
haven't seen those in a long time I
haven't either yeah it they that hair
did have a moment but yeah it went out
with jankos yes that was a while back
yeah well actually jankos went out a
long long time for that yeah I think
they did because I still remember seeing
people with hair well because like I
said this this episode was 2014 and I
mean I know the kids from Arkansas so we
might have been like a little bit behind
the times or something but it's like
yeah I haven't seen hair like that in a
while but yeah it did definitely look
like he just he just brushed his hair
into like a circle because it looked
like helmety like to an extent
so um so yeah so he says that while
they're doing the prayer thing
again now it starts picking on him
because he's like the third one so he
said the air started feeling like really
thick and muggy and he felt like
something was there but he couldn't like
put his finger on like he filled the
presence so that night Justin is in the
shower when the bathroom door creaks
open by itself
so he gets out and looks around like
what the [__] was that but there's
nobody in the hallway and then he goes
back into the bathroom he's brushing his
teeth and stuff and then the medicine
cabinet door like swings open by itself
and then like he goes to close it and
raw like another demon jump scare
because like the demons in the mirror
like hi you know what I mean it's like
that it was all a Dream well no I don't
think he said that one oh girl and I
don't think he said that was because he
said that he saw a hand come straight
for him and then he runs into his mom's
room to tell his mom about it and he
apparently has The Telltale three claw
marks on the back of his shoulder that's
right yeah so that apparently that is
really supposedly was something that
happens that is supposedly something
that really happened I was just talking
about the little girl the way that she
talked about her dreams in the book and
kind of in this like I wasn't real clear
on if the [__] was really happening or
not you know what I'm saying but but he
said he saw the demon in the mirror and
it scratched him so yeah so he saw an
apparition and it and it scratched him
yeah and it did like the three claw
demonic things things like that have
been reported before and the three
things man that [__] there were three
claw marks on the damn chain that locked
the door at math mountain and [__] I
heard it [__] break that damn chain
lock up off the inside of the door
Michael red came out I was sleeping on
the [__] couch it's looking terrified
he comes out of the [__] master
bedroom he says would you hear that
[__] yeah yeah I heard it what was
that I said it sounded like a chain he
went down and he came back up he said I
didn't see anything he didn't turn on
any lights or anything next morning
[__] found that down
chain hanging by a single screw and had
three
deep scratch marks it looked like it was
done with the dam you know those garden
rake the little yeah three claws it
looks like it was done with something
like something like that
but man it was weird that scared me when
I saw that it was like this thing could
hurt you yeah that's pretty weird yeah
that was the um
the second night
we were there yeah weird
it never did hurt you though but it it
could it was strong enough
I showed that to Red he's like [__]
what's up mango mango just arrived
all right so at this point like Chris
and Roseanne kind of think
you'd think that as Christian is they
are that they would like immediately
jump to demon but they don't seem to
they seem to they they definitely think
it's paranormal and like shit's haunted
right so they decide well we're gonna go
to the church for help so they go to the
pastor but the pastor doesn't do Jack um
basically they're just like well I don't
really know what to tell you except just
pray and I was like yeah they're already
doing that [__] and it's not
really helping
um now according to the voiceover uh
Anthony called the narrator uh their
faith only appears to make the entity
angrier like that's what it usually does
so at this point the cupid family calls
Branson paranormal in October of 2013
and like I said this is Wesley Fox the
guy from last week's episode nightmare
in the Attic uh and his wife Melissa who
they do paranormal stuff uh they didn't
mention this on the episode I might get
into it with the book later but they
also brought their uh Teenage I think he
was a teenage son at the time like named
Brandon or something like that
um so yeah so Wesley actually Brandon I
know
um Wesley actually wrote a book about
this case as I mentioned it's called
Deliver Us from Evil uh which I'll get
into a little bit later because I did
like kind of skim through there and
write some notes about it now so they
set up the EVP and all that
um Wesley asked the entity what it wants
and he claims that when he went and
listened to the EVPs back later he heard
like three voices in Latin and he had it
translated uh I think it was actually
the son that translated it because they
didn't say that on the show but he saw
in the book said in the book because his
son was like taking it in school or
something
um and apparently what the what the
voice said was it what it wanted
children's Souls
so you know of course you know they
didn't play the real EBP on the show
because they never do so I'm sure it
really wasn't and I think even in the
book he said oh well I you could barely
make it out and I was like yeah a bit
so his wife Melissa who calls herself a
psychic empath uh goes in the house and
is drawn to Brittany's room now she says
that she senses two distinct entities
one of them is Grandma obviously and the
other one she just calls a dark force
that she's not real sure about and then
she said that she started feeling like
really really bad hatred and negative
energy and then she walks out into the
hallway to find that it has suddenly
been transformed into a JC's haunted
house
laughs
covered with I know that's uncharitable
um it just it covered with fake spider
webs and fake spiders Larry's in there
saying that he just put on some Black
Sabbath and try to vibe
that reminds me of an old interview I
saw
back in the maybe mid to late 90s
of uh Violent J he's the
lead singer of Insane Clown Posse and
he's got his clown makeup on it and
everything and in this interview they
asked him how he came up with all this
and he said when he was a kid
the house he grew up in was haunted
he described perfectly Poltergeist
phenomena to the exact same thing that I
saw things moving things responded and
um
and and the age was right and everything
I'd like to be able to dig that up again
but it was it was a 90s interview of
violent Jay talking about he called it a
ghost
he didn't call the Poltergeist but he
called it a ghost
and uh he briefly you know in about a
couple paragraphs
told the whole story and I was like man
it was the same pattern and everything
that I you know and he's at the end he
said I just decided to just Vibe with he
said to just chill with the ghost and be
down with it and then it went away
because it wasn't fun anymore no ghost
was trying to scare him but he was just
it wasn't a ghost it was Poltergeist no
I know I'm just making a joke um it's
clouding the issue Jenny he what he did
was what he did was he resolved the
inner conflict
with himself and it uh the rspk went
away
but uh I believed him and even though it
sounded like
he was goofing around at first but then
when he told that story I could hear it
in his voice that that was real that it
scared him
and based on that he was always kind of
attracted to like the dark side of
things and a hidden knowledge of what's
really you know like what actually is
happening questioning things and that's
where he kind of came up with them he
liked rap music and he kind of came up
with this idea of dark clowns doing
[__]
rap music and comedy and [__] and
and I just I just you know I recommend
his interview at least the one that I
heard it was an early one
Zach says I thought you were gonna say
it was transformed into a JC Penney's
now that would have been really funny
but no um yeah she just walks out and I
was just kind of like oh look at all the
fake um you know this is fake spider
webs and it's like little fake spiders
like stuck on them and stuff like that
now she said that spiders were her
greatest fear so I'm presuming that's
why the demon was making her see them so
she said that like she couldn't breathe
and she had to run out the house uh the
show also kind of showed her like seeing
the demon in the hallways but she didn't
say she'd seen that I'll get a little
bit more into that later because she
said some [__] about that in the book
so Wesley and Melissa at this point tell
the family pretty much what they already
know uh you got two ghosts one's grandma
and one is a demon like they they even
did like the dramatic pause and I think
like while we were watching it like they
show like each family member and I was
like
is it definitely I was like they didn't
figure out it was a demon by now I'm
like why is that a surprise to anybody I
don't know but it's just like the way
that they framed it was like very funny
to me because it's like I don't know
it's just like overly dramatic I always
like this demon angle all right
these are Christians all right and the
United States basically culturally
Christian when you think of demons
you're thinking of things from hell you
know
but even in the Bible there's always
like this uh two different versions of
demons being talked about
punished Angels being enchanged into the
Earth
with I guess Satan in charge of them
which that's not quite what it says it
says Satan's in heaven it appears in
heaven a lot to test job and stuff
so is so what you're saying is is that
Angels Ultra powerful angels that stand
600 feet high and who could wipe out
entire cities
yeah this is about 600 feet spot size
for Godzilla I think it was 600 feet is
basically what it could oh my God has
anybody made that horror movie I haven't
watched that they're huge when one in in
later on you know in the New Testament I
think uh in one of the the one of the
gospels that says you know Jesus the
spirit appears you know after he's out
and and the cross and the big cross is
seen and I think I think that was a
couple hundred feet as it was described
but
it's just literature anyway the
then the other
demon that you're supposed to believe in
is demons that can possess pigs
and Jesus can cast them out and then you
know and you can cast out demons in
Jesus name so angels are getting inside
of people and causing havoc
or are they talking about spirits of the
Evil Dead
so there seems to be disagreement in in
Christianity of what a demon is that's
what I'm getting at
it definitely couldn't be an angel
a fallen angel why would it piddle
around and mess do little you know throw
things around in a room there's not a
power there
if if if if a demon really wanted to do
damage it could just destroy an entire
city
you know an angel just evidently had
destroyed [__] Sodom hegemora
just by wanting to there may have been
two of them but uh
so you know these are all stories
well yeah like I said I I wouldn't if I
was you can't really keep I would [__]
around with this like piddling little
[__] yeah they can't keep us
straight are we talking about angels
that are fallen angels are we talking
about spirits of the Evil Dead
you know an evil ghost is what basically
what I believe these demons if they
actually exist as described they're
talking about ghosts of evil people
that's that's the only thing it could be
yeah that would seem to make more sense
I mean none of it really makes any sense
but yeah that was if that's what it is
from a fictional thing from a fictional
sample because it wouldn't be an angel
it would just say [__] [__] your city
boom and blow up the whole city because
they have the power to
yeah but they never seem to have any
power in these stories very rarely are
they ever reported to kill anybody
yeah
yeah which like I said seems pretty lame
yeah it's like every now and then it's
like oh they they kind of scratch me or
like kind of push me down the stairs or
something I never really seemed to do
any serious damage no which leads me to
believe if this thing is an outside
force it's just an evil ghost yeah you
think and it's like pull your head off
yeah and it doesn't have the power or or
does not permit it in some way to do
these things to you
so yeah so they have this whole meeting
where they're just like yeah you got a
demon and then Melissa asks the 64
question 64 000 question uh has anybody
in the house ever experimented with
tarot cards or Spirit boards
so like Roseanne tries to be all slick
well yeah but I was a kid yeah and that
was a long time ago [__] son that
doesn't matter yeah that's all excuses
it doesn't matter just touching one of
those things yeah will just cause a
demon to latch on forever
now uh like Scientology says man you
gotta Theta now you got a body fading
well that's right so I'm just like okay
so you might be thinking and at least
the show addressed this even though the
explanation is pretty lame uh why did
the demon only just now start acting up
because apparently she hadn't touched a
spirit board in many years like since
she was a little kid what she said
something what'd you say Pokey
okay
[Laughter]
okay what are you talking about she's
complaining okay stop complaining poker
um but yeah so why did it start acting
up now Wesley's theory is that it's
because oh well the family just now
started getting back into being super
religious again and that woke it up
which
okay whatever I don't really know that
much about demons and that's
as good an explanation as any frankly
they're normally they're sleeping
they sleep a lot those demons they're
like super lazy but uh so yeah
now back when Roseanne was a preteen or
teenager you couldn't really tell how
old she was she looked about 15 or 16 in
the reenactment but from the book that I
read it seemed like she was probably
younger so her and a couple of her
friends were doing the spirit board
thing
and the spirit they contacted there they
did the whole like is there anybody in
the room yes will you tell us what your
name is and it said no but then Roseanne
was like well if you're really here then
give give us a sign and it apparently
like yanked her head back by the
ponytail
so you know I was like oh nice to know
that demons are just like mischievous
little kindergarten boys pulling on your
braid or whatever
so Roseanne said she felt really guilty
about playing with a Ouija board decades
ago and [__] up her whole entire
family good job Mom you know what I mean
it's just kind of like that it's just
like really funny
Melissa also tells them that the demon
wants Brittany because she's the most
innocent and loving of all of them and
oh there was some [__] about that in the
book and I'll get into that a little bit
too
so Wesley gives Brittany his little St
Michael's medal and says oh well I'm
gonna call up an ordained minister and
they'll come along shortly and uh you
know exercise the house which seemed
pretty easy because I kind of feel like
when it's Catholics and [__] they always
have like problems you know what I mean
like nobody wants to come and do the
exorcism or whatever
in early 2014 the demonologist Joe eater
turns up he was actually on the show the
real guy
um and he was wearing like this baby
blue priest shirt which I don't think
I've ever seen one of those and he had
like
um
he had like five o'clock shadow like he
had some stubble man he looked like he'd
been on like a few day Bender just like
when he was on the show I'm just kind of
saying
um so I kind of laughed because they
showed him he's like I bring the Bible
for this and I bring the candles for
that and I bring the medals for this and
I was like do you also bring the noise
yeah because just the way he said he's
he you could tell he was kind of trying
to sound badass and I was just like and
he also brings the noise but yeah so we
have a lot of fun watching these so uh
while they were praying like doing this
whole [__]
Chris said they could feel evil I don't
know what that feels like
um and heard moaning and groaning and
cracks and pops and [__] like that so
the priest starts yelling for the demon
to show itself and then Chris starts
taunting it like calling it a coward
saying what are you chicken like come
out and show us and blah blah blah and
then Chris like suddenly doubles to the
ground in pain like the demon just
kicked him right in the balls
um he actually said it felt like a spear
in his side but I prefer to think that
it just like kicked him in the ball you
said you don't know what evil feels like
I know exactly what it feels like had
you been to that house that was over
there in Boston me and Eric when you'd
feel it maybe not at first but after a
while you probably would
um it just feels like
for some reason you're just you're
afraid to be in there and you don't you
can't really put your finger on it and
then over sometimes it feels like
sadness and then sometimes it just feels
like it hates you it just it feels like
it's being projected onto you it's weird
it's weird you start questioning
yourself as like is this my imagination
you can know it can't be and then other
people pick up on it they feel the same
way about it
it's just a it's very oppressive
almost like it's draining you or
something yeah a lot of people say that
um so yeah so they're doing this they
keep praying there's like you know
they're shaking the camera and making it
look like an earthquake and [__] like
that but nobody said they said they they
saw that
so the priest is basically like just
ignore the demon being an [__] um you
know we're just gonna keep on doing this
and then the priest says he kind of like
meditates to get the Demon's name which
in this case is what the [__] did he say
avadu I don't know I was like what the
[__] I do or something I don't I'm not
really sure how to spell it like I
looked it up like real quick but then I
was like what the [__] am I doing I'm
like looking at made up demon names but
yeah I was just wanted to see if it was
a real wonder if they just pulled that
out their ass but yeah so he's like yeah
that's that's its name so once uh the
priest calls the demon by his silly name
uh it immediately disappears he's like
well you can't be here anymore and it's
like okay I guess that one like he
leaves and everything his blank back to
normal again I'm like wow that was easy
Tom asked something about dancing I
can't really read it how my glasses on
because what do you say didn't the evil
from danzig's boot transfer into you
once you touched it yes I did
that was that was if I can Venus de Milo
down Fenway in Boston he was up there I
was right front front stage man right in
front of the stage
it was a smaller show and I had these
three Japanese college girls all in them
damn 50s looking mini 50s school girls
skirts and we're all being pressed up on
the stage like that and Dad's singing I
[__] grabbed him and it [__]
transferred into me that's how I got so
checked I'm bigger than I'm big I got
bigger than him
foreign
so yeah so that was kind of the the end
of the story at the end Brittany said
and this is a direct quote from the show
I could feel Madness in the air when it
was there she said I was like that
really does not sound like something a
10 year old kid would say you know what
I mean just like the way she said it
sounded very very strange like it had
been scripted so that was like the end
of that show but as I said I actually
went through and read this dude's book
or skimmed it at least like went through
there and I wrote down some interesting
things that they probably should have
put in the show because you know I know
they can't mention everything because a
lot happens in the book
but
um okay from the book now Chris the dad
they didn't really go into this that
much but he actually claimed to have
been having paranormal experiences from
childhood including being able to see
spirits like he said he saw Spirits from
when he was as far as he could remember
he said that when he was six years old
he actually saw his grandfather's Soul
leaving his body like when his
grandfather died and he saw it
um now he said that this ability
Amplified after his grandmother died
like in 2003 and that he had like deja
vu all the time so he so they didn't
really go into this on the show that
Chris the dad like he wasn't a huge
character in it I kind of feel like they
focus more on the other people but yeah
he said he'd been having paranormal [__]
happen to him his whole life
now Roseanne too the mom she supposedly
grew up in a haunted house with her
grandparents and her grandparents knew
that it was haunted and they were like
yeah it's haunted you know what I mean
um she said she heard voices in the
house like felt like she was being
watched all the time there was also
supposedly an incident when she was at
school when like a door opened by itself
and then like she asked it to open and
close by itself and it did so she
started getting like really intrigued
with the Paranormal hence her doing the
thing with the spirit board because she
was like really interested in it like I
said I feel like they didn't go into
that all that much
now I'll also note that even though the
show sort of kind of low-key implied
that they had just kind of moved into
this house they actually lived in this
house and uh where what the [__] was it
Greenbrier Arkansas or whatever they
actually lived there for nine years
before [__] really popped off you know
what I mean now the kids had supposedly
been seeing shadows and [__] around the
house from the beginning but hadn't
really thought much about it like they
thought it was kind of weird but it
wasn't real overt
but the activity started to ramp up
right around the time like I said that
they started doing the daily devotionals
and going to church more often and stuff
like that but they'd actually lived in
the house for quite a long time before
anything like really overt started to
happen
um they also said that whatever it was
that was in the house made them argue
about everything like prior to that
they'd been real like chill and peaceful
and everything like that so that's
another thing that's very commonly
reported it's a bad house
it's a bad house maybe they seem to
think well I'll get into this a little a
little bit too
um and as I mentioned they didn't really
show any type of poltergeist activity on
the show but they in the book they
reported a lot of it did and they said
one of the things that happened all the
time was objects disappearing and then
reappearing in the same place a few days
later that's like Poltergeist that's
what I said like they said that happened
all the time
um and also they started hearing like
weird ass noises at night
um they said that Ryan's or Chris's
brother Ryan
um he would come over sometimes I think
he was a priest as well and he thought
that there was an evil he thought the
evil presence was coming from like their
bathroom closet like the closet in the
bathroom of like the the couple you know
what I mean so I kind of I don't know
why they didn't really mention that they
did like some stuff with the like the
kids bathroom and stuff but he said
that's kind of where the ground zero of
it was I've seen them both I've seen
Poltergeist I've seen bad house
I'd have to be there in this case to see
if it was one or the other
maybe maybe just because something
vanished and reappeared that didn't Nest
that maybe that doesn't necessarily mean
that it's Poltergeist maybe a bad house
could be so bad that it could have that
poltergeist-like effect
make an object
vanish somewhere and then reappear and
they may not be a poltergeist there it
might just be a bad place
some kind of psychic weird psychic
energy [__] with the dimensions or
something you know how do you explain
any of this we don't have a science you
know
it's some kind of an exotic physics
Stuart ammeroff would say it would have
something to the quantum physics Quantum
consciousness
maybe a location can have a
Consciousness to a certain extent
which would be kind of like the hotel
out of the damn lover look where it had
a consciousness of its own
and ghosts
Maybe
you know because if if humans
if humans have consciousness
and I'm thinking that animals have
consciousness
who are we to say that
inanimate objects might have a certain
kind of Consciousness under certain
circumstances it's just not one that we
really can yeah I don't know maybe that
sounds hokey
but
I don't know
maybe a place can have a consciousness
or or or a thing an inanimate object or
I don't know I don't know I'm just kind
of grasping
it's grasping out that I don't know
maybe a place could have something kind
of like a consciousness
that's all I'm thinking
Zach says I get deja vu randomly
sometimes and it's the weirdest thing
especially with situations I know I've
never been in before then he said I just
looked it up and apparently Deja Vu can
be a pre a pre-seaside symptom
well I'm not really sure I'm sure it
like auto corrected to something else
and also a sign of certain mental
disorders
yeah I've I've had it happen a few times
but not that many times
but uh but yeah so Chris's brother who
I'm assuming is a priest he came like
his name's Ryan and he came and did a
blessing at their house which they
didn't show in the episode and that made
the activity like ramp up even more so
now everybody is seeing these weird
shadows they call it like dancing
Shadows around the house they would see
them all the time not just the kids like
the kids saw them from the first thing
but they didn't think it was that weird
you know what I mean they just kind of
got used to it but after the blessing
then everybody started seeing them and
then like I said they started getting a
great deal of poltergeist activity like
you got dog toys like flying through the
air there was like a big wooden barrel
on the porch that moved by itself
bathroom faucets turn it on by
themselves [__] like that yeah it's all
sounds like like I said they didn't do
any of that in the episode I don't know
why that would have been a lot more
exciting
um also they all started I'm assuming
that they meant that they started
getting like really feeling really
drained because they said we would all
sit down on the sofa like in the evening
to like watch our shows and stuff and
then they'd all just start falling
asleep and then like a lot of times they
said they would be jolted awake between
3 and 3 30 in the morning seemingly for
no reason like the kids started thinking
their parents were coming in their room
and waking them up but their parents
said no we never came in your room but
they just thought somebody was in there
and it kept like waking them up and they
said the parents had that too
uh Justin started having nightmares
about a dark figure wearing boots and
carrying a staff I think it also had
like a hooded like a cloak or some [__]
like that
uh he also reported hearing boots
stomping in the house and the parents
apparently heard this too like it was
really really loud like somebody was
stomping around in Boots they didn't
show that on the episode either
um this was pretty weird Chris said that
one day I thought this was actually
gonna amount to something but I don't
think it did Chris said that one day
when he was at work like an elderly
couple approached him and said that he
looked troubled and they told him that
they were Prayer Warriors and they gave
him their phone number in case he needed
help I don't know if he called them
later because I was reading that section
I'm like are you gonna tell me that like
two old people like walked up to him at
work and they turned out to be ghosts or
something but I guess they were
but yeah they weren't ghosts they were
they were real apparently Larry Larry
writes that uh maybe maybe what it is
just like leftover energies in these
areas from other people would ever be a
ghost
Maybe
but yet we have to we have to accept
something that's like new newer
understandings of the mind and the brain
and Consciousness how it works when you
think of yourself and your Consciousness
and your soul you think that that's what
you are your Consciousness but actually
no your conscious waking self is just
one of the processes that your mind and
your brains is doing
that's kind of like the screen on a
laptop it's not the laptop most of you
is in the unconscious in the
subconscious that's where most of you is
and it's doing some [__] mysterious
[__] and it's in charge of your
consciousness
things that you think are your idea that
you consciously come up with now your
subconscious solved that and worked that
out a long time ago and gave you that
idea
and um
there's more than one of them in there
there's a multiplicity these different
it's like a committee
inside your mind discussing things over
and then hand in hand in the results
down to you
it's freaky when you think about it
so
so what kind of energy what kind of soul
is this where most of it is unconscious
can something like that exist in an area
kind of can a place have something like
that can an in a can an inanimate object
have an unconscious
I don't know
weird
when you think about it
uh okay let's see where was I oh yeah
the prayer warriors okay so not long
after this the family takes a short
vacation to Branson Missouri
now when they go there they wanted to do
a ghost tour thing I guess they'd wanted
to do it before but Brittany had been
too young and she'd been scared to do it
you'd think that since they were like
plagued by hauntings they wouldn't want
to do a ghost tour but whatever they
were like really into paranormal [__] I
guess now it was on this particular
ghost tour that they met Wesley Fox
that's how they met like they didn't um
you know say that in the show uh because
he was the guide on the ghost tour that
night so Wesley and his wife Melissa of
the Paranormal people they come to the
house to investigate just like in the
episode
um now Melissa apparently got a photo
that looked like it had four faces in it
like because they were taking pictures
and doing [__] also they got an EVP of
an older woman's voice saying pray which
they were saying was assuming was the
grandma and also one that kind of
sounded like a growl
here's something that I kind of wish
they put in the episode because this is
like pretty I don't know why this is
creepy but um Chris told Wesley that the
clock in Britney's room always stopped
at 3 45 even when they put new batteries
in it and Wesley told them oh that's
demonic I don't know why like that he
didn't really elaborate 3 45 isn't that
when the people got killed in the am in
the Amityville Horror no that was 3 15.
okay that's because that's the first
thing I thought of too right like yeah
315 that's why he kept waking up at 3 15
because they kept hearing like the
gunshots and stuff
but yeah
now Melissa said that she saw a Mist in
the house with a face coming out of it I
think this was right around the time
when she walked out into all the fake
spider webs and remember they showed her
like showing the demon she didn't say
the demon looked like a demon she said
that she saw a black mist and that there
was a face coming out of it and that the
face had a snout kind of like a dog or a
wolf but shorter and it had glowing red
eyes and then uh Wesley says you mean
like a gargoyle and she said yeah it
looked like a gargoyle like a gargoyle
face like coming out of the thing
so at this point Wesley tells the family
he's like yeah look you guys have to go
everywhere in pairs like all sleep in
the living room together like you know
just you have to go on the buddy system
because obviously this is like a bad
this is a bad [__] now Joe the
demonologist he actually sends the
family a blessing kit like through the
mail which I was like wow can you do
that okay so they can do the thing like
at the house themselves
like they bury property Metals around
the perimeter of the yard and so forth
now this actually like this was before
the demonologist even got there I think
like he just sent them all all the [__]
and they did it themselves and this
actually seemed to work for a while for
like several weeks
but then not long after Thanksgiving
like [__] started up again now a few
days before Christmas Chris woke up at 3
15 so maybe there was like an Amityville
Horror thing and heard like a huge crash
coming from the kitchen
so he goes out to check but he couldn't
find anything that could have made the
noise but then when he went back to bed
he heard the growling again but like in
his room and then the next morning
Brittany said she had heard the crashing
sounds too but she was like too scared
to go see what it was now this was what
I was talking about about the ambiguity
about like nightmares and real reality
because there's this kind of thing where
it's like okay Brittany was like she
said she had a nightmare but then he was
talking about it like in the next few
paragraphs as though it really happened
because she's like
um she woke up on Christmas Day and then
she opened her presents and then
Brittany went in her room and she got
like a new little journal or a new
little diary or something so she's in
there like writing in it in her bedroom
and then she looks up and she sees the
face of a teenage boy in her mirror and
like his clothes are all torn up and his
face is burned and he asks her why she's
there and then she's like because this
is my house [__] yeah and then
he says it's all your fault you burned
down our house like and I don't know if
this ever amounted to anything because
like the house didn't burn down
obviously but it's just like I don't
know that was like really weird so then
a few days later she's kind of forgotten
about that but then she's in her room
again writing in her journal again and
then she looks in her mirror again and
sees a little girl in there this time
who's wearing kind of like a little
flowery like sack dress or something
like that and like laughing evilly at
her and then a few days after that she
sees yet another person in the mirror
which is another teenage boy but a
different one like he's blonde whereas
the first one had dark hair and then she
said this one also had burns on his face
but not as bad as the first kid that she
saw and all of these kids like keep
saying it's your fault you burned her
house down like she kept having so I
don't know if she really saw that or if
she just kept having like recurring
nightmares about that it wasn't real
clear
so she apparently sees these people in
her mirror like every time she tries to
write in the diary and then she tells
her family about this but they just tell
her she's special and then she kind of
like brings the mirror out like can you
see anybody in it or something but I
don't know if this was part of the dream
like I said Just the Way It Was Written
was kind of ambiguous
now later on Chris and Roseanne have
been out shopping and they come home and
they find that every single light in the
house is on and then when they went
inside all the kitchen cabinets were
open
um and there was also like a dark figure
standing by the Christmas tree who they
described as being about seven feet tall
and then it kind of came like storming
at Chris and it sounded like the way it
was written was like it shrunk down and
then kind of went into him and then out
again
sort of
so they call the foxes again like uh
Wesley and Melissa the next day but it
would be a while before they could get
down there because there was like a big
snowstorm and like all the roads were
closed and [__]
now before the investigators come out
the family had some of the kids cousins
over I think it was it was a bunch of
other kids over and they were playing
card games at the table one night and
then all the cards started like
levitating
and then later that same night a carton
of milk or like a jug of milk like flew
out of Chris's hand when he was getting
it like to make dinner he said he felt
his hand burning and then like someone
just like smacked it out of his hand and
then they heard the growling again also
um sometime after that Chris woke up
with like a horrible pain in his stomach
and also lost his keys again with like
his keys where he always left them like
they weren't there and then like they
were gone for a bunch of days so you
know and then they kind of turned back
up again he said that happened all the
time so it's starting to go into
Poltergeist phenomenon right man I
wonder why this wasn't in the episode
that's what I was wondering because I
was like wow all kind of crazy [__]
happened in this [__] house like [__]
disappeared flying around unless they
change the story maybe I don't know that
they they saw the episode and they go
yeah
and then they go well we can make it
better than that and they write the book
I don't know yeah they're like weird we
need to add some [__] because she would
think that the haunting that they would
have eaten the eaten that up and had a
great because like I said that's very
cinematic yeah and yeah like later this
same day like that he lost his keys with
the horrible pain and everything he also
said that he came home and was putting
some stuff in their freezer like out and
then you know they had one of those
freezers like out in the garage and um
yeah and like something like pushed him
like against the freezer and then both
him and Roseanne then said they saw a
rocking chair that was in the garage
like rocking back and forth by itself
and then they went inside and tried to
light one of the one of the Blessed
candles that you know demonologist Joe
had sent but it wouldn't light and then
they heard like a disembodied laugh
um but then Brittany came in and got it
to light saying oh you just have to have
faith and she was the one that Lit it
they said the smell of sanctity yeah
there there we go again with that uh and
then later hey we got to get that as a
[__] clip we really do I gotta find
that somewhere and then later on Chris
said he was putting they've been playing
a board game and he went to put it away
and it got knocked out of his hands and
then when he was in the hallway he saw
this seven foot dark figure again with
like red eyes and he said it made a
booming sound like footsteps and like he
just kept having like really really bad
like abdominal pain all the time now the
family actually met up with the foxes at
like a McDonald's like at some point
later and Chris says he sees the figure
in the McDonald's that like it followed
them there
um and he says he sees it over in the
corner and then suddenly it would be
like right next to him again and he's
like and it's touching his arm and then
apparently while everybody is watching
like three red marks go down his arm
like after he says that it's standing
there so he goes in the bathroom with
Wesley's son Brandon and they hear
footsteps even though nobody is in the
bathroom but them so this was like out
of McDonald's
so around this time the Cupids have
actually been staying in a motel now
while they're out front talking to the
foxes a trash can behind them starts
rocking back and forth like violently
and then a bottle of coke like also
flies into the air on its own when Chris
reaches for it
um and it all sounds typical Poltergeist
like I said that's what I was saying
it's like I don't know why this stuff
wasn't in the episode
um also they see the hooded figure with
the staff that Justin kept seeing uh
they saw that in the motel room plus
they hear the evil laughter in the
growling uh the door rattles by itself
they go back to the house to do like the
another kind of Investigation slash
blessing type thing
um and then they had a motion detector
set up in the bathroom but it keeps
going off even though ostensibly nobody
is in there I will say this
um is that if it's a poltergeist case
it's very rare that an apparition is
reported in a poltergeist case like a
human or a humanoid looking one
um usually it's just
you know uh objects moving
yeah so who knows who knows about this
case are they mixing things did they did
they improve the story
who knows yeah
but see that's the thing so so this
motion detector keeps going off now
nobody saw anything except Melissa who
was apparently like the psychic right
yeah she said and this is how she
described it she said she sees a short
black figure that looked like a tall
spider except it had six legs instead of
eight with a humanoid face and Jagged
teeth what that's which uh yeah that's
pretty out there yeah and plus remember
on the show she said she was terrified
the only things during my Poltergeist
[__] episode went for a couple weeks
two weeks the only things that we saw
was like a blue haze that you weren't
you knew it was there but you really
couldn't look directly at it which I
described that in other places another
thing that we'd see is like a it looked
like something was what you could feel
something watching you you'd look up
this corner of the room and you could
kind of see a round clear ball there you
but you
not when you're looking directly at it
you can only see it kind of if you
looked beside it and me and red would be
doing [__] is that there we're like
yeah I think that's there and you know
it's not about that big right he goes
yeah and then and I go it's gone he goes
yeah it's not there anymore you know
just be [__] like that nothing ever
humanoid just like
disturbances you know what I mean like a
visual like an optical disturbance of
some sort
and uh the blue haze looked like some
kind of optical disturbance it didn't
look like blue cigarette smoke wafting
through in clouds it's just like a sheet
of even blue cigarette smoke but you put
when you got up close to it would just
vanish like
like a mirage you know just some kind of
optical Distortion of some sort weird it
was real weird and it didn't give off
any light or anything
uh but we played around with that for as
long as we saw it and then we stopped
seeing it after a while
it's weird but this thing about
humanoid type
you know [__] apparitions and spider
apparitions and [__] like that very
rarely reported in any credible
Poltergeist case that had a lot of
witnesses and outside Witnesses and cops
and News newspaper reporters come to see
it and they could see things moving but
they would never really see any
figures or anything you know well I kind
of feel like a lot of times when they
have when a psychic gets into the mix
like on this show they'll say oh they
saw this not the other thing and I'm
like yeah but she didn't really see it
like in front of your face like so other
people could see it they just see it in
their mind yeah like they just see a
vision of it which like I said I can see
lots of things in my mind yeah but
nobody else could see that [__] no it's
got to be objective yeah more than one
person has to see it all right and you
also kind of want some people that are
not
what should I say
[__] in in the direct Family Circle
like as soon as like neighbors like when
we went back went to Oceanside and it
happened at Oceanside too you know it's
all in the same episode and Lois's
friends saw it happen and Red's friend
saw it happen I was like we all felt a
lot better
that it wasn't just us seeing it that
other people could see it
you know because you knew you weren't
crazy then we knew we weren't crazy it's
just that we
we thought it wouldn't perform
for anybody outside the circle it would
make us look crazy that you know what I
mean like I'm not gonna do it when
they're around now they think you're
crazy and then when they leave it does
it you know no it would it would perform
a little bit like the same frog in that
cartoon yeah
every time you try to get it to perform
for other people it would just sit there
and Rib it we were paranoid that you
know we didn't really we didn't know
anybody at Mountain to help us or
anything you know it was before the
internet didn't know anybody in the area
so we just kind of kept it under wraps
until we got back
home you know which is Oceanside area at
that time for Lois and red and uh no
they saw it too because it it didn't
matter where it didn't matter it didn't
have to be at Mountain it was whatever
wherever we were
yeah they followed us if that's the way
it says we were
creating it the
it was rspk recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis it was a group synergy
Mia's main catalyst because it happens
here every now and then Jenny's seen it
which is not as strong as it was
some of our friends have seen it throw
the throne remotes and [__]
but you know you got it takes months to
ramp up
to get that to go
it's not something you could do on
command either
it's spontaneous
yeah yeah
um yeah so so the motion detector they
try to fix it but it just kept going off
uh I will note like I said that Melissa
was the only one who could supposedly
see the weird spider what's this that
was in the bathroom setting it off but
you know they just they couldn't get it
to like stop going off so they also did
like a bunch of EVP sessions and stuff
and Chris would basically tell them
where he could feel the evil presence
and they would take pictures like he's
like oh it's standing right here it's
standing right there or something like
that which is kind of like that other
Poltergeist case that we talked about
um now the photos I you know I haven't
seen them they didn't put them in the
book I don't think but um the photos are
basically just like a bunch of orbs uh
which you know whatever uh and one
supposedly showed something like a
shadowy something or other like standing
next to Chris and they said that
supposedly not too long after this
picture was taken he was actually pushed
violently against a wall
uh Wesley Fox the investigator said he
also got scratched by the demon during
this investigation uh there was also I
thought this was pretty weird but they
said they turned around and there was
like a a water bottle that one of them
had been drinking out of that was like
half full or something and they said
they turned around and it was turned
over and like balanced on its top like
on the counter or whatever that's a
poltergeist which like I said that's
Poltergeist stacking things up things
like patterns that'd be freaky
so uh yeah so the demons supposedly like
stepped up its attacks prior to the
final blessing that they did uh Chris
got violently ill again they heard like
the evil laughter the growling cabinet
doors all being open all the time
um this was pretty weird a large
skeletal hand print which appeared on
the seat of a stool like Justin was
going to sit down on it there's like a
big skeleton hand on it
um print of a hand yeah like a print
it's like it's pressure pressing down
right yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean that
was the impression I got from the way it
was described yeah
um you know [__] being thrown around by
itself stuff like that
um in the shower incident from the
program like where emo Justin was in the
shower and like you know from there
um hopefully he doesn't still have that
hairstyle but um I'm sure it is out uh
I'm sure he doesn't
um in that incident in the book they
said he actually heard someone saying
his name and saying his nickname which
is JC which they actually didn't show in
the episode which maybe he said after
like it kind of sounded like his dad's
voice but not you know what I mean so so
they didn't really get into that they
also didn't get into shortly after this
the same thing happened to Brittany
because they were like well why don't
you wait to take a shower for a little
while so then when Britney went in there
to take a shower
um she had the same thing have like she
had like a burning sensation like on her
back and then there were like at least
nine scratches on her back of her
shoulder and Chris said that the
scratches looked like they were trying
to spell something and they said the
word that it looked like it was trying
to spell was wife
which ew I mean the demon was like
claiming her she's 10. I'm like gross
demon pedo demon but yeah so uh I mean
they didn't put that in the show for
obvious reasons but yeah about that
point like I said it was just like
growling laughter yada yada and then
they did like the big final uh you know
exorcism just like in the episode and
apparently everything was fine after
that because Joe came and fixed
everything and they got a vadu or
whatever the Demon's name yeah it's not
a real well they're not real none of
them are real demons but
I never heard of a demon named that so
yeah all those stuff like you know
um
what do you call it like
like uh what was the name of that damn
diesel balzi Bob and all these uh yeah
names of these demons that all came out
of like Renaissance period and it's
because Rich dudes would hire guys to
write books about demons and they're oh
yeah we we write books about demons yeah
sure
it's [__] funny when you think about
it so you start writing fanfic and then
it becomes part of like religion oh
that's a source of [__] this is a real
Source book man it was just somebody
like smoking weed at all going woo that
sounds good books were
books were expensive only rich people
could afford them so there was a huge
industry in writing books for Rich dudes
and you could go to some rich dude and
go uh dude I got the I got this
information man check this out look at
this book it's all about demons really
where were the sources you're asking too
much Church all right we know all about
this [__] you know [__] and then you
know can't tell you if I give you 40
crowns yeah give me 40 crowns oh man you
know everybody likes to think they have
like secret knowledge yeah
doing the pages and the Beautiful
illustrations of damn
fly demons and [__] [__] you know of
course they're gonna buy that they're
gonna put that in their Library
that was the laptop of the [__] olden
days I mean I'd probably buy it too if I
had money not because I really believed
it was real but just because I thought
it was cool it works so hard man
would [__] encrusted with jewels and
leather and painted and [__] gold
thread and yeah they were styling man
really styling beautiful books yeah we
did a whole show on
uh Ivan the Terrible or I haven't I call
him Ivan a great all right Ivan the
Great's lost library that may be
underneath the Kremlin somewhere
I'd like to they even had a list of all
the books that he had in there and a lot
of them were books that don't exist or
don't exist anymore
some of them were never heard of and
Classics you know
and uh [__] from the Greek era some of
it Greco-Roman books but nobody's really
sure if that library ever really existed
they looked for it
it's like you know it's so much time has
passed it's like somebody might have
mentioned it somewhere and then somebody
might have mentioned that mention and
it's like you know it's a bunch of
underground tunnels underneath the
Kremlin to go back a thousand years
and uh
it floods periodically most of it's been
closed off even for [__] hundreds of
years
and it flooding happens in there I think
I because we did research on that with
shell on it I came to the conclusion in
my mind
that if that was ever there it got
flooded and all those books are
destroyed most likely likely yeah water
table got to it over time probably
is probably sealed away you know
door covered up so you wouldn't find it
you know
I don't know why he would take all those
books and hide them though it's unlikely
more likely he sold them yeah you would
think yeah I mean why would you just
stash them down there it seems right
I'ma stash him here in a secret vault
nobody will ever find it Well what good
are they going to do you yeah you know
you'll be dead you know in a few decades
so why why are you doing this yeah more
likely you sold them I would think yeah
yeah all right so uh are you ready to
wrap up what do you think about this
story well like I said I kind of feel
like I wish they had put more stuff from
the book into the episode because the
episode was a little bit
boring yeah I mean a little bit boring a
little bit repetitive
I'm gonna tell you what I think about
this I wasn't there
okay so I I would never be sure unless I
was there
I have a feeling just based on
everything that Jenny's dug up
that if this actually happened if it's
not a hoax what it was is a bad house
all right and then uh they decided they
decided for many different reasons
uh
usually it's a religious reason you're
trying to make money and get Church you
know get get Church followers and stuff
like that
um or to get street cred within the
churches then you embellish the story a
little bit
and it looks like it's got embellished
with some Poltergeist type phenomenon
I don't know if a bad house I've seen
them both I don't know if a bad house
can be so bad that it moves objects
Steve Mara might know he'd probably say
yeah there's some reports of it but you
can't confirm them you know
a lot of this [__] can't get me
confirmed you got to be there at the
time and then the phenomena doesn't last
very long then it's gone
you know if this was happening over a
period of time and all this massive
phenomena was very impressive
why weren't other people called in on it
when they go to the news
why didn't they go to the police
because in the infield Poltergeist they
went to the police
um and but they the police were friendly
it was England you know I mean the
priests were friendly enough to come and
you know calling their police you know
they're not armed [__] goons and [__]
you know or they're just kind of like
bouncers you know they may not have a
whole lot to do
um they're just like ooh this house oh
yeah let's go check it out
if you called if you called American
cops come over here we got a ghost that
hang up on you Mega we got [__] to do
they would never even respond to that no
of course and then instead of the police
showing up it'd be [__] mental health
showing up they'd arrest you and [__]
send you the damn mental hospital they
probably would and they'd take the kids
you'd lose them all right so we didn't
we were scared to say anything about it
um
I think it would if it if it was real it
was a bad house and it kind of blew it
out of proportion to help sales and
notoriety
and I think we talked about this a
little bit before but there is there
wasn't as much of that of of this in
this episode but I I'm always kind of
clued in with the whole oh used Ouija
board as a child and so a demon latched
on to you and that's what you get
um so I always kind of get that sort of
like satanic panicky kind of Christian
victimhood kind of narrative and I feel
like there's a lot of the later shows
went in that direction yeah because
there's definite troops
of that the core of the story in the
episode is
the house is bad being watched bad
feelings bad dreams we see things in our
dreams
the church came and got rid of it that's
the basic story yeah
that's a bad house
it's a bad house that's not a demon
that's not a poltergeist that's not rspk
or anything it's just I don't know what
a bad house is but I've seen him it's
just a bad place
it's a place that's strong with a dark
side you know like in Return of the Jedi
or if I can no was it not return to Jedi
what was that [__] Empire Strikes
Back where Yoda [__] goes going to
down or going to go in the tree over
there [__] you know what's in there
uh please you know nothing that you
don't take in there when you said okay
nac's Vader and they're seeing visions
you know it was a bad place
that's why Yoda was hiding there to
offset his good Aura he had to be next
to something that was bad so you
couldn't feel him in the force so the
emperor couldn't find him that's a good
[__] thinking I don't want to be
feeling Yoda yeah I couldn't be feeling
him through the force so he had a camera
he had to camouflage his presence by
being in a haunted area
or a cursed area which is kind of a cool
idea yeah
that's a cool concept yeah it was
supposed to be a Sith Temple a ruined
Sith Temple where a bunch of bad [__]
happened yeah
it's a Vader time he's probably human
sacrifice and training and sorcery and
[__]
I'm trying to figure out the [__]
secrets of life and death so you can
live forever and bring things back from
the dead and how do you do that you kill
a bunch of [__] and try to bring it back
so what do you think I guess you start
with mice and then you end up with
people kill that person and see if I can
bring it back that's some evil [__] when
you think about it like oh well throw
them on that didn't work go ahead we'll
try another one you try this time you
know and they must that's probably what
that's what they're describing in some
of these stories yeah yeah all right so
I guess we're gonna wrap it up we've
been going an hour and a half which is
longer it's twice as long as the actual
episode yeah yeah yeah but like I said I
did actually have the book for this one
too so that was kind of interesting and
there was so much stuff they left out
I'm making something to eat oh that
sounds delightful all right so uh be
sure to drop by again tomorrow we're
doing another movie review and it's
going to be the greasy Strangler from
2016 which I've actually wanted to been
wanting to see for a while and a couple
people have recommended it so we're
gonna watch that tonight and we will be
talking about that tomorrow so thank you
everybody for dropping by and we'll see
you guys again tomorrow bye